[Musique]
avis aux amateurs de sport et
électronique il ya un gros événement qui
commence demain au québec et qui va se
terminer culminé avec les demi-finales
et les finales à la place belle le
week-end prochain il s'agit du succès
une bêta chenal à qui est le plus
important événement de sport de histoire
qu'en fait de l'histoire d'ubisoft est
le plus important au canada maxime via
les chefs marketing et spécialiste des
histoires de chez ubisoft montréal
bonjour c'est bien alors c'est excitant
ça commence demain à en ligne donc vous
recevez à des joueurs d'à travers le
monde parlez-nous de l'ampleur de la
compétition de ea sports et jeunesse
proclamée le larousse a même accepté les
termes et l'emprunt 8 août a fait le
terme est utilisé maintenant
donc oui pour nous c'est vraiment le
plus gros événement de l'année on a une
circuit de compétitions qui se déroulent
tout au long de l'année des saisons et
le 6ème du thé chinois est vraiment la
culmination tout ça on attend 16 équipes
venues d'un peu partout dans le monde on
a des représentants du brésil du japon
de corée d'australie d'un peu partout en
europe
l'amérique du nord avec des joueurs
canadiens notamment aussi est vraiment
pour cette compétition qui est donc
celle de fin d'année on a le plus gros
prize money que l'on peut amener dans
cette compétition la plus grosse
cagnotte
oui ça y est on est on est on est déjà à
plus d'un million de dollars et on a
capté le prize money avec des mécaniques
de jeu partage de revenus avec les
équipes jusqu'à 2 millions de dollars
donc c'est vraiment une très grosse
dotation c'est ça la bourse peut
atteindre 2 milliards da a donné une
seule équipe à partager entre les
équipes en compétition les premiers s'en
partageront la plus grosse partie à
hauteur de 40% en somme oui et puis je
voyais que ça va être suivi par tous
global d'un million de visionnements de
mes 18 ans ça peut encore plus pour
cette édition nester environ combine
on espère faire un bon 50 % plus à 30 40
50% plus c'est ce qu'on vise
parce que c'est vraiment exponentielle
dans les notes du phénomène aziz bah oui
c'est vraiment un phénomène qui grossit
beaucoup on voit qu'elle plus en plus de
développeurs de jeux vidéo qui propose
des titres ea sports chez ubisoft avec
rainbow six idg c'était vraiment
l'ambition dès le début de ce projet
proposé un jeu assez riche en
expériences de jeu pour que les joueurs
puissent y trouver l'intérêt l envie de
passer du temps dessus qui soit
intéressant pour le spectateur donc qui
propose un vrai spectacle sur la durée
et puis voilà les dimension tactique
jeud équipes qui sont assez innovante
aux sports vous dites les rainbow sexy
gc le jeu qui va être à l'honneur
pendant cette compétition là on dit que
c'était un jeu de tir à la première
personne qui a été lancée en 2015 et
vous avez des dizaines de millions
d'adaptateurs faire aujourd'hui oui on
est on est à plus de 35 millions de
femmes depuis 40 millions même donc oui
on est on est un jeu qui marche bien on
est content on est on veut que ça
continue et 6 et 8 et schnell c'est
vraiment l'occasion aussi pour nous de
célébrer toute cette communauté tous les
gens en compétition mais aussi tous les
gens qui donnent à cette communauté qui
créent du contenu sur youtube
les fans artistes et aussi les
développeurs c'est pour ça qu'on le fait
à montréal c'est vraiment là la ville où
est développé le jeu où se trouve notre
équipe de développement et on m a invité
notre communauté ici ça crie combien
d'emplois à montréal on est plus de 350
à 400 à travailler sur ce projet sans
compter après tout les gens qui
travaillent à l'organisation de
l'événement on travaille avec un
partenaire local tribu expérientiel qui
nous organise l'événement avec des
partenaires aussi en europe qui nous
aident donc on est je pense plus de 500
personnes avoir contribué à cet
événement et vous allez en profiter pour
lancer la quatrième édition du jeu les
rainbow et qu'est ce que c'est un jeu
qui est très violent mais c'est un jeu
qui est basé donc c'est un jeu de tir à
la première personne mais qui est
vraiment centré sur l'aspect tactique
nous ce que ce qui est vraiment ressort
le plus surtout dans ces compétitions sa
dévotion de jeu en équipe comment les
joueurs vont arriver entre à s'organiser
pour sortir d'une situation difficile
bien sûr c'est basé sur le principe de
tir donc y aura toujours cette notion un
moment ou un autre il faut abattre
l'adversaire mais le but vraiment et de
mettre en avant les compétences de
travail en équipe et le côté tactique
donc ça commence demain en ligne en
virtuellement va pouvoir commencer
les premières compétitions et par la
suite ça se déplace à la place belle dès
vendredi prochain du commandement
on attend près de 3000 personnes oui on
est tout juste sold-out ça vient de se
terminer
parallèlement des derniers billets donc
on est on est hyper excité à l'idée
d'être à l'événement effectivement la
place belle c'est le plus gros le plus
gros endroit où on va se déplacer pour
l'instant donc vraiment très heureux
d'aller dans une arène de cette ampleur
alors on peut commencer à sévir dès
demain que vous recevez les participants
dès aujourd'hui c'est ça voilà il ya
quelques équipes ont commencé à arriver
hier hélas cet après midi je vais aller
accueillir les prochaines et dernières
qui arrive qu'ils vont encore
s'entraîner un petit peu aujourd'hui
pour être fin prête pour le début de la
compétition demain
eh bien vous souhaite vraiment un bel
événement et ce via merci d'avoir été là
ce matin
merci beaucoup au revoir